[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous présenter une expérience un
peu particulière dans une carrière de
chercheur à savoir celle qui est de
repousser les limites dans un domaine
scientifique alors en ce qui me concerne
ce sera plutôt la bactériologie c'est
une expérience peu banale je dois vous
l'avouer alors comme vous pouvez le
constater dernièrement mon terrain de
jeu favori c'est la mangrove la mangrove
de bord de mer donc pour beaucoup
d'entre vous mangrove c'est plutôt
synonyme d'un écosystème avec des
moustiques un peu agressifs de la vase
de la boue de l'eau un peu marron enfin
bref rien de très très engageant pour
aller passer vos weekends mais il faut
arriver à passer par dessus ça en fait
la mangrove de bord de mer peut vous
donner une eau relativement claire où
vous voyez en fait les racines de
paletuvier qui plonge dans le sédiments
des feuilles qui sont tombées sur le
sédiment on peut même y voir la faune et
la flore associé à cet écosystème
originaire de la commune du moule
j'adore cet écosystème où je peux venir
me reposer régulièrement donc moi je
travaille à l'université des Antilles
pardon où je étudie essentiellement les
écosystèmes marins côtiers type herbiers
ou mangrove
l'histoire que je vais vous raconter
débute en fait en 2005 ou lors de une de
mes sorties quasi hebdomadaires en
mangrove à nager dans cette mangrove
avec Palin tu vas à observer un peu ce
qui se passe mon œil a été attiré en
fait par des grands filaments blancs
accrochés à une feuille de palet de
suivi posée sur le sédiment marin étant
curieux de nature j'ai récupéré une de
ses feuilles je les ai ramené au
laboratoire en me disantiens je vais
aller observer ce qui se passe un petit
peu à ce niveau là de par la longueur
des filaments je m'attendais à trouver
quelque chose ressemblant peut-être à un
champignon des champignons marins il y
en a pas beaucoup ou alors à un animal
un peu particulier on peut étrange qu'on
pourrait retrouver dans ce milieu j'ai
donc décidé de pousser un peu mes
analyses avec des techniques de biologie
cellulaire et là je me suis aperçu qu'en
fait aucune des structures
caractéristiques d'une cellule animale
cellule végétale ou de champignons
n'étaient présentes dans ces grands
filaments la seule conclusion que je
pouvais avoir c'est que j'avais
probablement à faire à une bactérie et
c'est là que tout a basculé parce qu'en
fait une bactérie de cette taille ça
n'existe pas donc je vais vous présenter
la géante de nos mangroves géante
pacifique et voir les implications de sa
découverte au niveau de la bactériologie
en fait
voilà à quoi elle ressemble ça vous fait
de grands filaments qui sont accrochés
sur les feuilles qu'on va retrouver sur
le fond marin là la feuille est de
couleur un peu marron le filament est un
tube à la base et qui va se terminer
avec des espèces de boursouflures sur la
partie terminale c'est boursouflures ça
peut vous faire penser je sais pas moi
un chapelet ou plus prostaïquement à du
bout d'un créole on va rester plus local
donc cette bactérie elle a quand même
une caractéristique importante c'est sa
taille elle fait de l'ordre de 2 cm
alors pour un microbiologiste une
bactérie normale elle est 20 000 fois
plus petite ça pose quand même un
problème c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile à intégrer comme
ça d'un premier coup pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur c'est comme si on
avait découvert récemment une population
de primates qui ferait deux fois la
taille de l'Everest la plus haute
montagne terrestre vous voyez un peu le
problème le bouleversement que ça peut
créer c'est un véritable choc pour un
microbiologiste
cette bactérie géante en fait on a pu
l'identifier et il s'agit d'une bactérie
d'un groupe qui est connu qui est le
groupe des turmargarita
un groupe buveur donc une bactérie à
100% inconnue enfin le genre est connu
pas de souci de par sa forme un peu
particulière nous au niveau du
laboratoire on l'avait appelé Thomas
Margarita créer au bout d'une en lien
avec ce boudin créole alors il faut voir
que comme tout travail scientifique
c'est un travail d'équipe on a travaillé
on était une dizaine de chercheurs il y
avait des chercheurs donc de
l'Universités Antilles des chercheurs de
France hexagonale des États-Unis et les
premières observations sont de 2005 mais
la publication est de 2022 ça fait quand
même un laps de temps de 17 ans pourquoi
aussi long d'abord le temps de la
recherche fondamentale ça prend du temps
mais aussi on avait on était on était
face à un organisme tellement
particulier tellement hors norme qui
nous a fallu multiplier les analyses
pour être sûr de ne pas les raconter des
bêtises d'être l'arrivée de tous en fait
on a dû mettre ceinture et bretelles
pour être sûr de pas annoncer des choses
un peu trop hasardeuses on a quand même
réussi à publier ces travaux qui sont
sortis dans une des revues les plus
prestigieuses dans la science
actuellement qu'il a revu science
donc ce turmargarita a créé le boudinus
en fait on l'a pas publié sous ce nom-là
on s'est dégonflé pour la publication
scientifique on a pris un nom plus
académique et on l'a appelé Thomas
Margarita Magnifica ça vient un peu
mieux alors cette bactérie elle a quand
même des grosses caractéristiques la
taille je vous en ai parlé mais bon la
taille ça ne fait pas tout c'est qu'un
produit d'appel il y a encore d'autres
caractéristiques intéressantes d'abord
le génome elle a un génome qui est 3 à 4
fois plus important qu'une bactérie
standard normale qui dit ingénome 3 à 4
fois plus important dit que cette
bactérie code pour 3 à 4 fois plus de
protéines donc déjà on est hors normes
par rapport au monde bactérien classique
ensuite elle est capable de multiplier
les copies de son génome alors vous êtes
pas forcément tous scientifique à la
base mais on apprend ça même très jeune
au collège ou au lycée qu'une bactérie
c'est un organisme mini cellulaire de
petite taille invisible là c'est déjà
raté qui contient une molécule d'ADN qui
correspond à un génome
classique pour une bactérie se
génométant libre dans la cellule chez
Thomas guérita Magnifica nous avons pu
mesurer d'oser jusqu'à 700 000 copies de
ce génome 700 000 on explose tout ce qui
était possible et admis en bactériologie
c'est énorme pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée nous mammifères être humain etc
dans nos cellules nous avons deux copies
de génome petit joueur que nous sommes
comparés à Thomas Margarita seulement
deux copies alors notre génome est
beaucoup plus grand mais mine de rien
une bactérie comme tout Margarita
Magnifica a plus d'ADN dans sa cellule
qu'une de nos propres cellules
cette bactérie est vraiment
extraordinaire elle chamboule vraiment
tout mais c'est pas fini il y a aussi un
niveau de complexité cellulaire qui
était complètement inattendu au niveau
des bactéries en fait tu Margarita
Magnifica de par cette très grande
quantité d'ADN à une partie
particularité c'est qu'elle va être
capable d'empacter d'entourer ces
molécules d'ADN dans des membranes et ça
va vous former des espèces de petites
vésicules qui vont être contenues dans
l'intégralité de la cellule comme on va
vous montrer c'est l'animation 3D chaque
petit grain bleu que vous apercevez ici
correspond à une de ces petites
boulettes qui contient l'ADN qu'on a
appelé des pépins
vous voyez qu'il y en a énormément sur
tout le pourtour du filament et ça
jusqu'à la parution de notre article en
juin 2022 c'était quelque chose qui
n'était pas connu du tout chez les
bactéries ce n'est un processus qui
n'existait que chez les cellules
animales végétales et ou les champignons
donc on explose là encore tout ce qui
est possible au niveau de ton Margarita
magnifiques
ensuite je vois certains d'entre vous
qui peuvent commencer à s'inquiéter
peut-être un peu en se disant bon les
bactéries elles sont quand même
responsables de la mort de centaines de
milliers de personnes de par le monde
par des maladies infectieuses et
peut-être qu'on est allé réveiller un
géant endormi qui nous faudra beaucoup
de mal alors je voudrais vous rassurer
tout de suite d'abord pour plusieurs
raisons si elle était pathogène ça fait
17 ans que je nage avec je la manipule
avec les doigts afin que je prends
aucune précaution jusque là j'ai pas vu
des faits négatifs en tout cas lié à ça
donc ça devrait pas être pathogène
deuxièmement les bactéries sont
essentielles au bon fonctionnement des
écosystèmes et des organismes nous être
humain on vit en gros avec 10000
milliards de bactéries synthétiques sur
la peau dans le tube digestif un peu
partout on a besoin des bactéries pour
avoir un écosystème fonctionnel un
organisme fonctionnel donc
quel est le rôle de cette bactérie c'est
souvent une question que les gens se
posent moi je vous poserai une autre
question a-t-on besoin d'avoir un rôle
précis dans la nature pour pouvoir
exister je vous laisse méditer
profondément sur cette question
métaphysique mais vous verrez que la
réponse est pas forcément si facile bref
donc on peut se dire qu'elle est pas
pathogène le rôle précis on ne l'a pas
vraiment en fait c'est un géant
tranquille pacifique qui vit dans les
mangroves au milieu marin qui va
utiliser les sulfures produits par les
sédiments marins le carbone qui est
dissout dans l'eau sous forme de CO2 et
va mener sa petite vitre tranquille
alors on a plein de questions pour
lesquelles on n'a pas encore de réponse
par exemple est-ce que cette bactérie a
des prédateurs vu qu'elle est très
grande est-ce qu'elle a des prédateurs
pour l'instant je vous dirais que son
seul vrai gros prédateur c'est moi j'en
prélève quand même un petit peu mais je
pense pas qu'il y a d'autres prédateurs
que ça autre question un peu plus
sérieuse est-ce qu'elle n'existe en
Guadeloupe est-ce qu'il y en a ailleurs
dans la Caraïbe est-ce qu'il y en a
ailleurs dans les mangroves du monde
est-ce qu'on en trouve dans d'autres
environnements non marins on n'a pas la
réponse pour le moment quelle est sa
vitesse de croissance pour faire ces
deux centimètres cette tache gigantesque
est-ce qu'il lui faut deux jours deux
semaines deux mois on n'est pas encore
clair par rapport à tout ça est-ce
qu'elle produit vu qu'elle produit
beaucoup de protéines est-ce qu'il y en
a quelques-unes qui ont un intérêt
important qu'on ne sous-estime encore
peut-être avec des retombées médicales
enfin bref plein de pistes disponibles
pour nous dans l'avenir ensuite il y a
une autre question qui est très
importante on se demande si cette
bactérie est une sorte d'accident
évolutif en fait est-ce que c'est la
seule qui a fait plein d'ADN avec des
compartimentations etc ou est-ce que ça
existe dans l'environnement sur d'autres
types de bactéries alors on est
chercheur on est allé encore chercher un
petit peu et petit scoop entre nous dans
les mangroves
on va trouver des grandes bactéries
filamenteuses positionnées comme ceci
alors ce que vous voyez ici ce n'est pas
une bactérie c'est un filament bactérien
vous avez des espèces de galettes comme
ça qui sont chacune des bactéries d'une
même espèce et en fait ce que vous voyez
ici c'est qu'on a marqué en vert l'ADN
et donc on retrouve cette
compartimentation sous forme de
structure vésiculaire qu'on avait appelé
des pépins qui vont exister également à
ce niveau là en fait cette notion d'ADN
compartimentée à l'intérieur de membrane
qu'on ne pensait réserver qu'à des
cellules animales végétales ou à des
champignons il semblerait qu'en fait ce
sont un processus beaucoup plus répandu
que ça y compris dans le monde bactérien
donc l'existence de Margarita nous a
même permis de repousser complètement ce
qui était connu admis pour la
microbiologie donc c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel cette bactérie là on l'a
retrouvé dans les mangroves de bord de
mer c'est pour vous montrer l'importance
de ces mangroves on a peut-être tendance
à trop sous-estimer
dans les années qui vont venir dans les
dessiner des décennies pardon qui vont
venir faut pas oublier qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique le changement
climatique la montée des eaux etc les
moins graves vont avoir un rôle
extrêmement important pour nos régions à
différents niveaux ça va déjà protéger
de l'érosion des côtes premier point ça
peut aussi servir de protection ça sert
mais ça servira pour des larves de
poissons de crustacés qui vont à
l'alimenter les herbiers les récifs
coralliens là aussi c'est essentiel la
preuve que c'est encore un réservoir de
richesse extraordinaire on va pouvoir
avoir au niveau de ces mangroves donc
c'est impératif
de les protéger de prendre le temps
d'aller les observer mettez-vous à l'eau
mettez un masque un tuba regardez c'est
une atmosphère qui est tranquille il y a
rien qui va vous attaquer il y a pas de
bête dangereuse profiter de ce spectacle
pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est Clément
Grove on estime que depuis 30 ans 40 ans
on a perdu 30 % des superfices mangrove
de Parlement donc il est essentiel pour
nous de protéger ses membres la
Guadeloupe a eu une phase un peu
critique aussi vis-à-vis de sa mangrove
je vais pas vous refaire l'histoire de
la Guadeloupe d'abord j'ai pas le temps
pas les compétences mais globalement la
zone de par exemple de Jarry autour de
l'aéroport c'était bien des zones qui
étaient de mangroves actuellement la
tendance est inversée des organismes le
Conservatoire du littoral comme le parc
national protège ses écosystèmes nous
pouvons tout un chacun se mobiliser pour
protéger cet écosystème
donc que tu Margarita Magnifica ce géant
que l'on vient de mettre en évidence au
niveau de notre écosystème devienne une
emblème de ces mangroves et surtout que
nous ne mobilisions pour elle moi gonfla
c'est en nous faut nous protéger pour
nous-mêmes et pour petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]